Sur euh, toutes les,
tous les items, toutes les points d'entrée euh. Du texte,
euh, nous avons vu 1 durcissement, mais qui allait
jusqu'à reprendre les thèses du Front National,
les propositions concrètes du Front National.
C'est le cas évidemment pour l'aeme,
l'aide médicale d'État
qui est dans le programme de Marine Le Pen,
sa suppression,
c'est le cas sur le regroupement familial,
c'est le cas sur la nationalité,
c'est le cas sur l'ex étudiant,
c'est le cas sur euh,
euh, l'aide au développement,
euh supprimé lorsqu'il n'y a pas de euh de de.
De collaboration suffisamment efficace des pays en
en en en remise de laisser passer consulaire,
c'est le cas sur la nationalité,
c'est le cas sur la déchéance de nationalité. Bref,
il y a comme ça, euh,
j'ai envie de dire,
1 trentaine de points
sur lequel on retrouve très
exactement les propositions qui a pu
faire Marine Le Pen
et précédemment le Front National sur ces sujets, euh.
Et donc euh. Ce qui est assez frappant,
c'est qu'au fond, ça a été euh.
C'est le le texte de. De la clarification,
c'est-à-dire que la ligne politique de LR, désormais,
c'est bien ce qui a été évoqué souvent,
mais qu'on avait pas toujours euh
touché du doigt de manière aussi précise et concrète
et factuelle, euh.
Le fait d'aller sur euh.
Les propositions de l'extrême droite